is there anything more satisfying in
cs:go than hitting a clean crisp bullet
to the dome
well maybe getting out of silver I um it
wouldn't know I'm calling for the score
you sports and this week on top ten
we're talking all about head shots baby
now there's been six years of
competitive csgo that's six years of
melon melting armor-piercing headshots
and picking the top ten of those was
nearly impossible we did it anyway so
from pistols to ops from wallbangs
to one taps near the top ten hedge [ __ ]
here are the top ten head shots in csgo
the first play on our list is a historic
case from envious is happy at Dreamhack
open London 2015 after four beautiful
head shots and one slightly less
beautiful kill happy earned himself a
permanent spot in csgo history at
somebody peak on envious side head well
that's what happens when you go around
the corner happy with juan deag the free
is like sweating bullets
coming in at number nine are the
now-infamous body wall bangs against
Astralis during ESL pro league season
five body manages to hit not one but two
head shots through the wall from spawn
in one map shots so insane that valve
actually had to patch them out of the
game
of course yeah but it was done really
just hit way that was from Zika done
through the top of the roof as if things
couldn't go from bad to worse that is
Player of the Year
just put that in there as the epitome of
this game and all this floor is insane
boom what is trying it again no you
can't possibly do that twice that roll
he's got the line up perfect and then
walk into it twice that is Wow Wow
the number eight play on our list puts
the spotlight on fanatics olofmeister
who absolutely dismantled na'vi and a
1v5 at ESL one Katowice 2015 oh yeah and
he did it with four back-to-back tec-9
head shots and soos look at that running
and gunning takes down JW and all the
points the tank line and AMA it's really
really good combination but unless they
fight in one of the time oh my father
they will pronax
helping out with that kill and Guardian
going down and it's now a triple kill
for love - he's got plenty of help
through this as well Suz is very low C's
although my god he gets another Kilian
now cops running out seven seconds one
of my Sookie for the kill five seconds
it goes through a shot and it's gonna be
long round at number seven is a creative
play from ni pees get right in the
loser's bracket final of starseries
season 12 getting a boost from Oulu get
right hits an absolutely disgusting
mid-air head shot with the tech 9 on
device that just shouldn't be possible
look at get right he's gonna go for the
style play does he land the drop does he
land the jump event call it now does he
do it no it's gonna adorably this
position he's looking to jump up on the
sky and he's gonna do it they already oh
what get right tagging down to face
mid-air with the tech 9 device is going
to be furious how does that even happen
back at it again at number 6 is get
right this time at ESL pro league season
4 semi-finals get right shows off his
laser focus with this near instant flick
on Toofer hitting this wall bang
headshot with the narrowest of margins
people around after that yeah right Oh
what is that reaction yeah right get out
fur and now fallen he's on top of the
roof but waterful shot coming in at
number 5 is a play that comes from
Dreamhack open cluj-napoca 2015's closed
qualifier a dren managed to secure this
insane 4k clutch to win this round
against Wizards with the final kill
coming from a mackworthy 180 degree
flick to some poor souls face
[Applause]
fresh like a food five seconds cute five
Sanka old to scream is a name synonymous
with one taps in our number four play
from CS summit 2017 he didn't even have
the luxury of the second chance but
still managed to connect his lone ache a
bullet with furs melon on purpose screen
makes me scream one head shot is nice
too is impressive three is nearly
superhuman but for what in God's name is
this play from snacks it just snacks
that's fine one on let's not leave him
out of this the Big Apple and snacks is
hungry he's got one kill already of the
USP low HP is well on Guardian and flame
he's trying to beat them out trying to
get between the bye-bye
I've never seen anything like it what
the hell was that that's gotta be sick
is based on classes I've ever seen and
the entirety of csgo how do you top four
back-to-back headshots well try five
with our runner-up play from envious XMS
at the pgl europe minor championship
2017 XMS melts all five members of team
kinguin with only five bullets pretty
good the difference thinking what's
going to allow me to help out actually I
was gonna better go and take all three
EXO that's what the deep suddenly turns
its around though goes head it takes two
lives we gonna go down oh this man is a
monster the taps right now go further
gets himself a good three bullets three
kills that's to watch out you knew there
was a playoff here the woods they get oh
my god what is wrong with you it's gonna
go ahead and get poor this might as well
be fired four bullets the whole round
positioning being this distant is
actually quite reasonable in spiro try
to better than one in five shots five
shots five kills taking the top spot on
our list is a play that has etched
itself in csgo history we've all seen it
a million times and it ages like a fine
wine so sit back and watch in awe at he
goes still in human reaction but it is
too late
carriage is gonna be waiting he co
charges in doesn't she quads
human reactions King Cole
not even whether the aim but could you
have got that kill in hiko he stood in
the one on three almost unwinnable
position but that is a terrifying
message to anyone who ever dares to
challenge he code you might end up being
cutting being killed just like that
exist we'll get the last one but surely
that is gonna be a kill that will go
down in history well guys that's our
list for this week now if you do
disagree with it I advise to load up a
name map and practice your headshots
don't even comment don't app me I don't
want to hear it thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]